the russian advance is still slow much
slower than the kremlin thought or will
admit to but it is advancing
new satellite images show that the 40
kilometer convoy that was stalled and
bogged down outside kiev for more than a
week has finally started to disperse
the russians want to encircle the
capital but it hasn't proved easy so far
and will probably only get harder for
them as they get stretched thinner
no means will you put the people of
ukraine on their knees
ukrainians are not afraid and even in
the occupied cities they go out unarmed
on actions against the occupiers
we will kick you out of every inch of
our land we will not give up together we
will withstand
the ukrainian government is furious
about this
russian forces have allegedly kidnapped
the mayor of mellitupal and it was
caught on cctv
[Music]
and this was the reaction in the city
itself they want their mayor released
this does not look like a city about to
succumb to occupation
[Applause]
in the last 48 hours the russians have
been targeting air force bases to put
ukrainian fighter jets out of action the
vasik live base was hit this morning
on saturday afternoon the french
president a man in macron and german
chancellor olaf schultz held a 75-minute
phone call with president putin they've
asked for an immediate ceasefire but
they've agreed to say nothing more about
the content of the call for now which is
intriguing
uh
diplomatic
diplomats are working and discussing
certain details of the agenda one that
can be discussed between us and russia
i would like this to happen so that a
settlement process a peace process can
be started in reality in practice and
not just in words a process that would
lead to ending the war
processes for ending the war are being
discussed i'm already happy to receive a
signal from the russian side in
principle
time is running out for anyone left in
mario paul it is surrounded and under
siege
conditions inside the city are desperate
the international red cross says that
food and medicine has all but run out
there is no gas and so there's no
heating and they're melting snow for
water they are literally being starved
to death or surrender
having failed to walk into the cities as
liberators
russia is now strangling the life out of
them
alastair bunker sky news